Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain the 2014 short comedy
drama film called “Leonard in Slow Motion.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The protagonist of the movie is a middle-aged
man named Leonard who has a unique quality.
He exists in slow motion but lives in a regular
speed world. Everything Leonard does is at a
slower speed in general, not because he is lazy
but because it is just how he was born. His
drowsiness also applies to the things around him,
like the liquid he touches flows in slow motion,
defying all laws of physics.
At the beginning of the movie,
we see him running to his workplace, in slow
motion of course, while the world around him
moves normally. At work, his colleagues make
fun of how he pours his coffee into a cup.
They have worked with him for quite a while but
his unique quality never fails to surprise them.
Leonard has a crush on his colleague, Sheryl but
has never had the guts to confess to her. Every
time he tries to talk to her, he stutters. Because
of that, plus his slowness, Leonard has never been
able to utter a word to her. One day at work, his
boss calls him aside and praises him for coming
to work early and leaving late, but complains
that his productivity is very low because of his
“quality”. To make up for it, he invites Leonard
to his kid’s birthday party as a performer.
Leonard reluctantly accepts the request and
performs tricks at his kid’s birthday. He bursts
a water balloon in slow motion to entertain them.
It is clear from the trick that Leonard’s power
bends the laws of physics. Sheryl, who is also at
the party, cheers for him. His boss knows that he
likes her and asks him to go start a conversation
with her. Leonard confidently approaches Sheryl
but stops when another guy starts talking to her
first. This has been a usual thing for Leonard.
He is so slow that he is always preceded
by others in every aspect of his life.
Later that day, he returns home in disappointment.
His day gets even worse when his boss calls to
inform him that Sheryl is wanted at another one of
their offices, so she is moving to Florida within
a week. On the brighter side, his boss claims
that the kids were very happy at his arrival
and loved his water balloon trick. Leonard
knows that his boss is taking advantage of
his uniqueness but he cannot quit his job
because he wouldn’t get one somewhere else.
At night, While watching the TV, a news
report catches Leonard’s attention.
An energy drink called the Shox beverage is
being sued for providing people with too much
energy that they go into cardiac arrest. It turns
out that a malfunction caused a Chinese herbal
stimulant called Chailow to overflow during the
production. Till now, a total of nine people have
been hospitalized due to cardiac palpitations,
and dangerously hyperactive heart rate.
The advertisement of the drink says that one shot
of Shox will provide you with eight consecutive
hours of energy. Although the news report
asks the people to not consume the beverage
distributed within the last week, Leonard gets a
brilliant idea. He wants to try the energy drink
and see if it will increase his speed and turn
him like everyone else. However, he cannot find
the energy drink in shops as they have been told
to throw them away because of health reasons.
So the next morning, Leonard brings his friend
to every dumpster in the town, looking for a
pack of Shox that the shops have discarded. After
searching for hours, he finally finds a cartoon
full of the drink in a garbage bin behind a
convenience store. In the following scene,
we see him chug down several bottles of the
energy drink, hoping it would make him normal.
Lo and beyond, the drink works and Leonard can
perform activities at a normal speed now.
He speaks for the first time in the movie, and
says “this is amazing”. He then throws punches
in the air, fascinated by his own speed. Tying
his shoelace is an enjoyable task for him that
morning. Even pouring himself a cup of coffee,
which doesn’t take forever to fill the cup,
makes Leonard’s day. He puts more effort than
usual to run to work that day. Excited to do
whatever he couldn’t when he was slow, Leonard
first tells his boss that he is quitting the job.
He then runs to Sheryl who is in a meeting in
the boardroom. Leonard excitedly barges in,
disrupting the meeting, and says that he wants
to ask her a question. Sheryl and the rest of the
room anticipate the question but it never comes,
as at that moment, the effects of the energy drink
wear down. Sheryl asks him if he is okay to which
he embarrassingly and slowly replies that he is
fine. All of a sudden, Leonard’s stomach starts
to grumble. The amount of energy drinks he had
yesterday is finally making him sick. When no one
expects it, he projectile vomits through the room.
His co-workers, including Sheryl, watch in disgust
as the vomit slowly falls all over the desk.
Even his vomit doesn’t follow the rules of
gravity. Everyone then gets out of the room,
leaving an embarrassed Leonard alone. His boss
comes in after a while and asks him to clean up
the mess before leaving the job forever.
In the following scene, Leonard walks into an
old age home where he has gotten a new job to take
care of the old people. The job is perfect for him
as the people there are as slow as him which
makes him feel included and normal. He is
way happier there than he was at his previous
workplace. Leonard also writes a letter to Sheryl
apologizing for ruining her meeting and asking her
to visit the old age home as it is pretty close to
the Florida office that she has transferred to.
In the last scene, Leonard is in a swimming pool
where Sheryl joins him, indicating that
they have finally started dating.
The fans have called “Leonard in slow motion”
a movie that is ahead of its time because of
its bizarre, yet thoughtful concept and excellent
execution. Although it is only seven minutes long,
it leaves an impression on every viewer. Some
fans have speculated several theories on what
Leonard’s uniqueness denotes in real life. They
believe that it is meant to signify how people,
especially youngsters, feel like their life
is going slower than their friends and family.
They are always comparing their achievements
to others, not realizing that they all have
their own uniqueness as Leonard did. All of them
are going at their own pace and will eventually
achieve the things they want to. If they try
taking shortcuts to life, they might also end
up vomiting all over their workplace.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thanks for watching.